all right well our good day to las vegas
team checked in with metro sheriff joe
lombardo this morning
uh to talk about a couple of things few
actually local crime
domestic terrorism and also drug
problems in our valley here's what he
had to say
so we've wrapped up 2020 and we're now
well into 2021. let's take a look back
if we can
crime in the valley last year broadly
speaking what did metro see
what state is our crime rate in
we're down 13 percent and overall crime
numbers
that's a big deal because when you look
across the nation
in particular i'm a member of major city
chiefs which is the largest
66 i believe is the number now police
agencies across the united states and
we exchange our crime information on a
regular basis and
we're one of eight jurisdictions that
had a decrease in crime
let's change gears a little bit we back
on christmas day there was an explosion
in downtown nashville we've seen events
that took place in washington d.c
the issue has been brought up about
domestic terrorism extremist views that
are
taking a violent turn what does metro
police do to try and
root out possible domestic terrorism
threats
here in las vegas and around clark
county um
we can we have all the resources
available to counter terrorism squads
and
the fusion center and everything else we
can to be
proactive and prevent an event from
happening but more than likely
we will not be aware of it unless you
call us
an individual that knows another
individual that might be in middle
distress or made some comments
intending to cause harm to the public we
need to be aware of that
and and we need to follow up on the
information
when we're provided to it well sheriff
as we're all battling
coronavirus there's another sort of
epidemic here in the valley that
we've talked about before that has to do
with overdoses and
the use of illegal drugs um
what kind of a trend are you seeing is
the department seeing in that regard
across the community as we're
we're doing dealing with the pandemic
and also this issue with regards to
overdoses
we've had a thousand percent increase in
overdose deaths since 2015
so you can't ignore that number right so
in particular to the overdose deaths
the significant i guess the common
factor
or the significance of it is fentanyl
and that's a synthetic form of heroin
slash opioid
that's been on the street for a few
years now and it's caused
devastation across the board it's it's
it's a hundred times
you know people tell you different
levels of uh
lethality associated with it but it's a
hundred times more lethal than
than the street level um heroin that
people are
usually familiar with and you don't know
what's in that in that
chemical combination and that's
what people have been dying from
if you have a question for sheriff joe
lombardo you can submit
it on our website at 8newsnow.com and
then you can find out if your question
was answered by joining us
every wednesday morning